hi
this is steve kaufman founder of link
and i'm going to speak to you about the
secrets the seven secrets to successful
language learning
i have learned 11 languages four of them
since the age of 50. i'm working on my
12th which is korean
um i will tell you what works for me
you'll have to decide if this can work
for you
the first secret to successful language
learning is spend the time
when i study a language
i spend at least an hour a day
trying to learn that language
and i know that it's going to take me
months and months
of continuous
studying
to learn the language
but
when i say study
i don't mean sit in a classroom i don't
mean answer questions or drills
or review grammar rules
or review lists of words
what i mean is spend time with the
language
be with the language so
listen to the language or
read things about that are written in
the language or listen to songs that are
sung in the language
watch movies if you can
if you have friends who speak the
language spend time with them even if
most of the time you're just listening
because you don't speak well enough to
really say very much spend time with the
language that is the first secret and i
say at least an hour a day and it's not
difficult to do because nowadays we have
these very convenient little listening
devices like an ipod or an mp3 player
which can carry vast libraries of
interesting content that you can easily
download from the internet or from
wherever you want to find them this is
very different from many years ago so
when i say spend time with the language
the time you spend in the classroom
almost doesn't count what matters is how
much time do you spend away from the
classroom with the language the
classroom can be very important as a
place for you to meet with your friends
to find stimulus from a teacher but in
the classroom you're listening to the
teacher half the time or you're
listening to your
classmates some of whom might be better
than you
in which case you're afraid to speak up
some of them are worse than you and so
you find it annoying to listen to them
perhaps i know i do
but the important thing is how much time
do you spend with the language away from
the classroom listening reading watching
movies
listening to songs
talking to people spend that time with
the language and do it month after month
after month and don't let too many days
go by where you don't spend time with
the language
and depending how difficult the language
is and that means how different it is
from your native language or from a
language you already speak
the amount of time
required
might be
years if you can only spend an hour a
day
it could be six months to a year to two
years if you can spend three hours a day
then it might be less than a year but it
does take time there is no shortcut to
fluency so my first secret and it's it's
absolutely essential if you're going to
make any progress in language learning
spend time with the language so that's
secret number one and i will continue on
to the other six secrets there's a total
of seven secrets to successful language
learning thank you for listening